les gens essaient de créer des
fondations depuis plus de 50 ans la
fondation a eu une énorme influence sur la
guerre des étoiles
c'était le plus grand travail de science-fiction
de tous les temps
l'histoire est tentaculaire la portée est
tentaculaire elle se déroule
sur mille ans
si jamais il y en avait  une entreprise qui
espérait améliorer la vie des gens
grâce à la technologie grâce à la connectivité
c'est apple et c'est quelque
chose qu'asimo espérait faire
tu vas m'arrêter demain
et toi
c'est presque une certitude que
tu connais mon travail psychopathe
histoire oui en théorie mais je ne sais pas
ce que ça doit faire ce n'est pas une théorie
ils s'inquiètent que tu puisses prédire l'
avenir
[Musique] les
gens inquiets croient que je peux
et ils n'aiment pas l'avenir je prédis
[Musique]
le  l'empire tombera l'
ordre
disparaîtra il y a des événements massifs qui se précipitent pour
nous rencontrer
seulement le week-end avant l'obscurité
[Musique]
vous